Film Courage: You’ve talked [previously]
about when you attend Tisch for Film and Television,
what was the curriculum regarding writing
at that time?
If you were to take [those classes] today
and teach there today, what would you add?
What would you change?
What would you keep the same?
Daniel Calvisi: Well, there wasn’t a ton
of screenwriting when I was there.
My favorite class was Screenplay Analysis,
no shocker there.
The first produced screenplay that I read
was in that class.
We read the SILENCE OF THE LAMBS which was
a really great script.
It was interesting because that script was
exactly 120 pages and they always say one
page equals one minute so it was exactly 120
minutes (2 hours) and that got me thinking
Hmm, how would this writer know that he was
going to end exactly two hours in (120 pages
in)?
And then in the course of the class we learned
about structure and how important structure
was and that was structured exactly to end
on page 120.
Film Courage: You said there weren’t too
many classes on writing there?
Of course the ones that were there, you loved.
Dan: At that time, yes.
Film Courage: How would you expand on
it today?
What would you add to the curriculum?
Let’s say they invited you to come back
as a teacher or professor?
Dan: Well, I think I would definitely emphasize
television, the long form scripted television
writing form.
And I would probably emphasize low-budget
filmmaking, writing something that could be
shot on a low-budget.
Now films are being shot on iPhones and they’re
getting released in theaters and they’re
getting nominated for awards and winning awards.
So I would go in and tell these kids they
probably already know it but you can shoot
a movie on anything, on any topic, on any
type of equipment and if it’s good and has
a great story, it could have an afterlife
but it still has to have that great story.
So it doesn’t matter what technology you
use.
I would say learn about screenwriting and
learn about structure and focus on the writing
first.
Film Courage: In terms of the actual breakdown
of writing a screenplay, what do you think
you focus on more, structure or dialogue?
Dan: For students?
Film Courage: Yes, if you were to come back
as a professor and have say with the curriculum.
Dan: I would most definitely focus on structure
most.
I think just flowing, short, tight storytelling.
There is nothing better than a two-page scene
that really advances the story and surprises
us and brings up and turns direction and shows
us an element of the character that we didn’t
see coming.
It’s all about surprise and subverting our
expectations.
That’s why it’s so important not to have
clichés because the audience (the reader)
doesn’t want to know what’s going to happen
because it’s compelling if they’re surprised.
So I would probably emphasize that, structure
and surprising storytelling, not cliché storytelling.
Film Courage: So you went into the program
thinking about the industry and knowing there
were certain films that you wanted to write
in a similar genre and voice.
When you came out of the program, what did
the real world show you?
What was an eye-opener?
What was a disappointment?
What was more of an unplanned joyous discovery
about the industry?
Dan: Well, it took me awhile to realize that
working in the industry at a day job, you
don’t have to be creative.
They don’t want you to be creative unless
you’re in a creative position.
So I was so obsessed with selling a screenplay
and directing my first film when I was in
my early 20’s and I was doing my first day
jobs as interns, as administrative assistant,
as a reader and I was always looking for a
way to impress the boss that they would eventually
bankroll my film or buy my script.
What I didn’t realize was it was all about
working hard, put your head down, work harder
than the next guy and then if you work hard
enough and they believe in you because you’ve
worked so hard and shown that initiative and
taken any job out there no matter how (any
task they give you no matter how bad or ugly
or gross or whatever take that job do the
best job you can at it do it 120 percent and
that’s what’s going to get you hired,
that’s what’s going to get you the better
position to move up the ladder.
Film Courage: When you say that they don’t
necessarily want people who are creative,
that’s interesting.
So even if you’re a fantastic writer it
doesn’t mean you’re going to get a certain
job where writing skills aren’t at the forefront
of what you’re doing?
Dan: Yeah, like if you’re working in development
your job is to evaluate material and develop
material for your employer’s company.
It’s not to write your own script, it’s
to find material that’s right for your employer
and then development that material so it can
be a greenlit film.
So if you’re a screenwriter working in development
let’s say and your an assistant to a creative
director or director of development at a studio,
they don’t want you to be writing your screenplay
two hours of the day, they want you to support
them in finding great material elsewhere.
Film Courage: Do you think internships are
good for someone coming out of film school?
Dan: Yes, I definitely think so.
It can be challenging because how do you pay
your rent if you’re working at a free internship?
And that’s one challenge that I had, as
well.
I used to do temp work.
I used to do administrative assistant temp
work at the time and try to do internships
at the same time which was challenging.
But definitely internships the main advice
is just work hard, work harder than the next
guy.
Film Courage: That sounds like a lot, how
did you juggle that?
Dan: Well it was tough.
I would try to get temp jobs, I would tell
my supervisors at the temp company that I
wanted jobs that were only like one, two or
three days and then hopefully that would make
me enough money maybe for a couple weeks and
then those two or three days that I wasn’t
working that week I would go into the internship
at the film company.
It was tough but I figured it out somehow.